Hello and welcome the fire of learning.
What is your name?
Is it peaceful? Ruler, Noble
Lady, watchful man of justice.
The last one is actually my name,
but I think you know me better as Justin.
Names are strange. We all have
one. We use them every day,
but their meanings are
often unknown to us.
Many are remnants from ancient times
or products of ancient languages.
Very often. Both were named after
religious figures, gods and Goddesses,
great leaders and warriors, noble
qualities, or even just strange things.
You wouldn't expect to be a name
and we don't even know it. Well,
in this video we're going to look at the
meaning behind our names and discover
they're mysterious origins,
so let's get to it. Robert.
Robert is a name with ancient dramatic
origins from probie and Barta,
which together mean roughly shining glory.
Jennifer.
Jennifer is a Celtic name roughly.
It can be translated as
white wave or fair one.
Michael and Michelle from Hebrew.
Mikael, it's an unusual name.
It means who is like God.
Question Mark,
I rhetorical question implying and no
human is like God. Katherine, Kathy,
Katie, Katelyn, Kathleen, Greek names
associated with the ancient Greek word,
ketosis, meaning pure Richard.
Richard is an ancient dramatic name.
It means strong or hardy ruler.
Rick is coming and many names.
It's the part that means ruler Rachel
meaning you as an female sheep.
There are many names
which are still around,
not because of the original
meaning of the names,
but because the names are
shared with certain characters.
Oftentimes biblical characters in
this case, Rachel from the Bible,
Thomas Thomas is from the
Aramaic language. It means twin,
but it's popularity began
with the biblical character.
Thomas the Apostle Jessica,
Hebrew from east Saika,
which means foresight one who can
see the future. David, a Hebrew name,
which means beloved, referencing
the biblical character,
King David, Emily, Amelia,
Latin names both derived from aimless,
meaning persevering or industrious.
John, Sean Jean, Ian Evans, Shane,
Joanne, Joanne, Jane, Janet.
Believe it or not,
all variations of the same name.
Jean is the [inaudible] of
the French word [inaudible],
which we came at John and England,
Sean and Shane in Ireland.
Ian Or yon and Scotland,
Evan in Wales,
and then of course you have
some feminine equivalents.
They all come from the Hebrew
yohannon which means graced by God.
Nathaniel and all its forms are from the
Hebrew Natan l God has given Margaret,
Megan, Molly, Maggie, Marge aggression.
Paygee Margarita is actually a
Persian name, which means Pearl.
Megan and Molly were originally
nicknames for the name Margaret,
but became their own names over time.
Not Uncommon for that to happen
actually Justin, Justine,
a justice from the Latin that
Justina was or use tineas.
It means man or woman of justice in
my man of justice. I like to think so.
Elizabeths and Isabella. These names
shared the same Hebrew origins.
Hit means roughly oath of God or
God is satisfaction. James, Jim,
Seamus, Jacob, Jake, Coby, Jamie,
Diego, Jacqueline. Once again,
many names of the same origin.
Jacob was the Hebrew name.
Yakima's or James is the Latin equivalent.
The origin of the name is disputed.
It may mean supplanter
follower or protected by God.
Merriam at Mary Maria Murrey,
another name with uncertain origins.
It may be ancient Egyptian and
mean beloved or maybe Hebrew,
meaning rebellious or even
bitter or harsh. C of course,
though the focus being on Mary,
the mother of Jesus,
Jack Jack has uncertain origins. That
used to be a nickname for the name John,
but then became a nickname for other j
names like Jacob and James and eventually
became its own name, possibly related
to the French name, Jacques Kimberly.
This name became popular in the 19th
century because of John [inaudible] House,
the first Earl of Kimberly.
It is old English and means the royal
fortress and the woods. Jeffrey,
Joffrey Godfried.
This name is derived from a Germanic,
specifically old French source,
meaning God's peace.
Rebecca Rebecca is ancient Hebrew for to
tie firmly made popular by the name of
the wife of Isaac and the Hebrew Bible,
Fredrick Fredrick.
Ancient dramatic origin,
meaning peaceful ruler.
Rick is also a nickname for Richard and
a few other names. Stephen, Stephen,
Stephanie, a Greek name meaning
crown or honor. Amanda. Amy.
Amanda is a Roman name,
meaning worthy of love.
Amy is the French version from a May,
which means beloved well, Liam, Liam,
well bill well Hamina, a name of
dramatic or agenda related to Ville helm.
Effectively a strong willed warrior.
Melissa. Melissa is a Greek name,
meaning honeybee after the Greek
mythological character. No, I say us.
The honeymoon. Joseph Josephine
Josephina from the Hebrew Yosef,
meaning God shall increase related of
course to Mary's husband and the Bible.
Laura Lauren.
Laurel.
These names shared the same Latin origin
believed to be derived from the Bay
Laurel Tree. Cameron, a Celtic name,
meaning a crooked nose. Susan Sue,
Susie, Susanne. This name is derived
from the Persian word for lily flower,
Charles Carl Carlos, Chuck Caroline,
Caroline, Charlotte, Charlene,
dramatic and origin meaning free man
or free woman. Danielle, Daniella.
Danielle, meaning God is my
judge. Referencing of course,
generally Daniel in the lion's den from
the Bible. Debra, another name meaning B,
this time and Hebrew popularized by the
character in the Old Testament. Donald,
a Celtic name from [inaudible],
meaning ruler of the world.
I'm sure the common section. We'll have
a ball with that one. Hannah and uh,
and Nancy. All from the Hebrew
word, meaning grace or beauty.
Chris, Christopher, Christy,
Christina, Kirsten, Kirsten,
Kristen, Christian, Krista,
all derived from Greek for Christ
bearer or follower of Christ Ruth.
He roof, we're friend made popular
from the biblical character,
Kenneth meaning either handsome or fire
born victor, Victoria, Tory, Vicky,
all from the Latin for victory Victoria
was the Roman equivalent of the Greek
Goddess Nike, the goddess of victory.
Brian Brenna, Brianna, Brianna Brina,
a Celtic specifically Irish name in
origin, meaning esteemed or noble.
Tiffany from the Greek name Theo Fanya,
meaning manifestation of God.
Aaron made popular by the biblical
character of the same name.
The origin is unclear but may lie in
ancient Egypt, meaning warrior lion,
Julius Julian, Juliana, Juliana,
Gillian, Juliet, Julie from Yulia.
Is it common name in ancient Rome?
Made popular by people such as of course,
Julius Caesar,
possibly a reference to the god Jupiter,
Kevin from the Celtic convene,
meaning of noble birth, Sydney,
likely from the Anglo Saxon, Seton
Iga, meaning water meadow, Matthew,
a Hebrew name from Matatu,
gift of Yahweh. Natalie,
believe it or not, not the feminine form
of Nathaniel. It comes from the Talia,
meaning Christmas and Latin
Timothy from the Greek Tim Otiose,
which means honor to God, destiny,
a name from the Latin at Destin. Ra.
What the same meaning as an English
Patrick Patricia Patty from the Latin
[inaudible],
meaning a nobleman or noblewoman made
popular by people such as a Saint Patrick
Clair, likely derived from the Latin
Clara, which means bright or clear Eric,
the Viking name, meaning
soul or eternal ruler. Leah.
Leah has a name which could
have multiple different origins.
It could be Hebrew and mean, tired.
Celtic meaning light of the sun is Syrian,
meaning female ruler or
Greek meaning good tidings.
Corey Corey is probably a Celtic name,
which could mean ravine or hollow.
Abigail. Abby, gale meaning my
father is joy referring. Of course,
the God made popular as the name of the
wife of King David, Brendan, Brendan,
Brenda, most likely to be
of a Celtic Irish origin,
meaning prince or Princess
Nicholas, Nicole, Nick,
Nicky from the Greek Goddess Nike,
the goddess of victory. Shannon,
a reference to the river
Shannon in Ireland,
which means why is river Jason
from the Greek? Yes, sewn,
which means one who heals,
made popular by the ancient
Greek hero of the same name,
Alexander Alexandra Alexis Lexi,
Alex Lex from the Greek Alexandros,
meaning defender of the
people or Helper Kelly.
It is a Celtic name from Kela,
which may mean warrior,
pious or bright headed
Anthony Tony Antonia.
Antonia was the name of a Roman family
who claimed to be the descendants of
Anton and mythical son of Harris.
Please Linda. Linda is a dramatic name,
possibly meaning shield or a gentle
Joshua from the Hebrew Yoshua,
which means God is salvation.
This became Yazoo is in Latin,
which is the name attributed
to Jesus Helen Alaina.
The name origin is uncertain,
but the popularity is owed to
Helen of Troy in Greek mythology.
Mark Marcus Martin Marteen,
a Latin name from Marco's
all references to Mars,
the Roman God of war. Cynthia
Cindy related to degree, God,
Artemis who was born on Mount Synthes
in Greece. Paul, a Latin name,
meaning humble,
made famous by Paul the
Apostle Angela Angelo Angel,
Angelina from the Greek on gallows,
meaning angel or Divine Messenger.
Gregory Greg from the Greek Gregorio's,
meaning watchful or alert. Joyce,
either a Celtic name doc,
meaning Lord or lady related to Saint
Jude Doc or rejoice and English Edward and
Anglo Saxon name meaning guardian of
prosperity related to the word warden
Alice, Alicia, Alicia, Alyssa,
Adeline at Alina Alison from the
ancient dramatic at elitists meaning and
nobility, son and a name generally
originates as son of Ronald.
Ronald is a viking name probably
meaning the decision of the ruler.
Veronica from the Greek Bharani k
meaning the woman who brings victory.
Frank Francis Francesca.
The name has a relation to
the Franks who founded France,
meaning free person Brittany related to
the Celtic region of Brittany in France.
Scott meaning a man from Scotland or
speaker of Golic as there Vanessa Nestor
from the Persian word for star related
to Queen Esther Peter from the Greek
word,
Pedro's meaning stone and influenced the
chorus by Saint Peter Taylor related to
the occupation,
someone who works with clothing.
Diane Diana from the Roman Goddess. Diana,
the equivalent of the Greek Artemis,
the goddess of the hunt and
childbirth. Ryan, a Celtic name,
lively meaning something
like little King Marissa,
either Latin for of the sea or even
little Mary George from the Greek dealer
goes, meaning husband or farmer.
Leslie, a name from a place in Scotland,
meaning Haldi Garden. Gerald Gerry,
Geraldine Gerard, a Norman name,
meaning rule of the spear.
Shelby in Anglo Saxon.
Name it from a place name meaning
village by the Celebi trees. Albert,
Alberta, a dramatic name meaning
noble and Bright Henry. Hank Harry,
Harriet Henrietta from the dramatic
Hainer. Rick's meaning ruler of the home.
Coleen related to the Irish word for girl,
clean meaning woman of the country,
Benjamin from the Hebrew
Binyamin son of the right hand.
Samantha Samuel,
a Hebrew name meaning God has heard
after Samuel and the Hebrew Bible,
Adam from the Hebrew,
odd how Dama meaning earth or soil
after the biblical Adam Chelsea in old
English place name meaning chalk port,
possibly related to Kelsey,
which means ships, island
or victory. Phillip, Felipe,
Philippa from a fellows and hippos and
Greek meaning lover of horses. Kayla,
Mckayla from Hebrew,
meaning full of joy.
Mack is usually a Celtic family name
derived from the word for some Todd from
the old English word for Fox,
Ashley and Anglo Saxon name
from a place name ash and Lee,
a forest of ash trees, Andrew,
Andy, drew, Andre, Andrea,
Andrea, meaning strong or masculine.
We've gone over well over a hundred names.
Now hopefully you saw yours, but if
not, if there's a video does well,
I'd be interested in making part two or
if you already know it or having more
unusual name, feel free to tell us
about it in the comments section below.
For more videos like this and
videos on many other subjects,
I'd invite you to come check out fire
learning and to subscribe to keep up with
these videos in the future to help
support the cost of production of fire of
learning does take donations on Patrion
the link to which you can find in the
description. Even just a $1 contribution
helps. Thank you for watching.